lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
demostrar que si una función es
derivable en un punto c también será
continua en ese mismo punto pero antes
de hacer la la prueba recordemos lo que
significa la deriva habilidad y la
continuidad muy bien así que vamos a
empezar con la propiedad de la deriva
habilidad muy bien y eso es una
propiedad de las funciones verdad y por
lo tanto vamos vamos a hacer un breve
dibujo digamos que tenemos aquí los ejes
digamos este es el eje ye y este es el
eje x muy bien y digamos que tenemos
alguna función no sé digamos algo así
digamos algo que se vea algo así y
queremos ver que esta función es
derivable en cierto punto c muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos el valor de la
función en sí
aquí tenemos fdc y por supuesto esta
función o ésta es la gráfica de la
función yo igual a fx muy bien y
entonces una forma de calcular la
derivada en el punto c sería de la
siguiente forma tenemos tomamos
cualquier punto digamos x por aquí y nos
fijamos en su evaluación con la función
f verdad entonces acá estará digamos fx
verdad y ahora calculamos la la
pendiente de la recta secante que une
estos dos puntos verdad la recta secante
que une a efe
al punto se coma fcc con el punto x coma
fx verdad y calculamos la pendiente
ahora la la idea de la deriva bilidad es
simplemente hacer tender x ac verdad y
entonces eso es lo que nos va a dar es
una pendiente es la pendiente de la
recta
gente en el punto de verdad y tangente
por supuesto a la gráfica entonces
tenemos que calcular el límite cuando x
tiende a ser de fx verdad menos fdc
menos fdc todo esto sobre x menos c
verdad si nos damos cuenta esta
expresión que tenemos aquí es la
pendiente de la recta secante que une
estos dos puntos si en ahora nosotros
incluimos este límite estamos calculando
la pendiente de la recta tangente muy
bien y todo esto es sólo un repaso
verdad si decimos que nuestra función
efe es derivable en c lo único que
estamos diciendo es justamente que este
límite existe y en dado caso de que si
exista esto es lo que conocemos como la
derivada de f
punto c
muy bien ahora vamos a repasar lo que
significa la continuidad muy bien vamos
a ver qué significa que una función sea
continua en algún punto y para eso vamos
vamos a usar otra vez algunas gráficas
pero en realidad la definición de
continuidad solo nos dice que el límite
de fx cuando x se aproxima a c debería
ser justamente lo intuitivo que es
evaluar efe en el punto c ahora quizás
es más fácil ver el caso donde una
función es discontinua muy bien vamos a
ver varios casos bueno veamos son los
dos casos digamos aquí nuevamente
tenemos nuestro eje y digamos que acá
tenemos nuestro eje x y tenemos alguna
función que se vea más o menos así y que
en el punto c tenga un agujero y digamos
que la evaluación en el punto c vaya por
arriba y después continúe por la gráfica
muy bien digamos que aquí es
el punto ce pero la evaluación de la de
la función en ce está hasta acá arriba
muy bien entonces si nosotros por
ejemplo quisiéramos calcular el límite
cuando x tiende a c es decir
aproximarnos a este punto
digamos que quisiéramos aproximarnos a
este punto verdad entonces la función se
aproxima a este otro punto verdad
entonces realmente aquí se encuentra el
límite cuando x tiende a c df de x
verdad entonces no fue igual el valor de
f
ence que el límite de fx cuando x tiende
a ser verdad veamos otro ejemplo porque
digamos que
tenemos otra vez nuestros dos ejes aquí
tenemos que x
y digamos ahora que tenemos una función
de este estilo que viene por este lado
por aquí y después hacer todo un brinco
hace todo un brinco y continúa nuestra
función donde hizo el brinco digamos que
ese es nuestro punto c entonces si nos
fijamos en la gráfica aquí es aquí se
encuentra f evaluada en ce muy bien
sin embargo ahora si nos aproximamos por
la izquierda hace en realidad nos
estamos aproximando a este valor si nos
aproximamos por la derecha entonces nos
estamos aproximando a otro valor
completamente distinto entonces en este
segundo caso el límite no existe ese
límite no existe el límite cuando x
tiende a cdf de equis y entonces no
podemos decir que la función sea
continua ahora si hacemos un último
dibujito de algo que sí sea continuo
digamos algo más pequeño
digamos algo así muy bien aquí está el
eje x el eje y digamos ahora sí que
nuestra función se ve como como las de
siempre entonces aquí sí tenemos que la
función evaluada en se corresponde con
el límite verdad porque si nosotros
ahora nos aproximamos por aquí entonces
la función se aproxima a este punto
mientras que si nos aproximamos por la
derecha entonces la función se aproxima
bien a ese mismo punto entonces en este
caso si podemos concluir que coincide
con el límite cuando x tiende a ser de
la función f x muy bien y hasta hasta
ahorita todo esto fue un repaso y es un
repaso necesario para ver lo que
queremos demostrar en este vídeo y es
que la deriva bilidad en el punto c
implica que va a ser continua la función
en ese mismo punto sé muy bien entonces
vamos vamos a revisar la demostración de
esa afirmación que íbamos a hacerlo
digamos por separado
hacerlo por separado vamos a poner unas
líneas digamos así y entonces comencemos
suponiendo vamos a suponer
supongamos que f es derivable en c muy
bien que significaba que la función
fuera derivable en c pues significa
justamente que es el límite que tenemos
aquí arriba exista verdad y en ese caso
le decimos que es la derivada de f ence
muy bien entonces vamos a calcular el
siguiente límite calculemos el límite
cuando x tiende a c de fx menos fdc muy
bien tenemos ese límite entonces si
nosotros queremos calcular este límite
vamos a utilizar un truco vamos a
multiplicar por x menos vamos a
multiplicar por x menos c f x menos fdc
pero para no afectar la igualdad
tendremos que dividir entre lo mismo
verdad podemos dividir entre x menos c
entonces si te pones a pensar lo
realmente multiplicamos por 1 verdad y
eso no le hacen
a la expresión que teníamos
anteriormente la única ventaja que
tenemos ahora es que tenemos el límite
de un producto y sabemos que si ambos
límites existen pues corresponde al
límite al producto de los límites verdad
lo que quiero decir es lo siguiente
tenemos el límite cuando x tiende a c de
x menos todo esto que multiplica
límite cuando x tiende a c de fx menos
fdc / x menos sé muy bien entonces esto
simplemente fue utilizando la regla del
producto de los límites verdad ahora si
nos ponemos a pensar qué significan
estos dos límites por un lado el del
lado derecho es justamente la derivada
de f evaluada en ce verdad esto es
justamente suponiendo que f derivable en
c entonces este límite existe y le
llamamos f prima de c por otro lado el
límite de x - cuando x tiende a c pues
es justamente 0 verdad x - sí sí si x se
parece a c pues que x se va a parecer a
0 verdad entonces el límite anterior que
calculamos es exactamente
muy bien y esto para que lo necesitamos
bueno ahora regresamos a nuestra
expresión original muy bien tenemos que
el límite de fx menos fdc es igual a 0
fue lo que encontramos en los argumentos
pasados ahora muy bien
recordemos que el límite de una
diferencia es la diferencia de los
límites entonces tenemos el límite
cuando x tiende a ser de fx menos el
límite cuando x tiende a c de fdc y esto
obtuvimos que vale 0 verdad sin embargo
fijémonos ahora en este término tenemos
el límite cuando x tiende a ser de fdc
pero eso ya no depende de x verdad este
numerito es simplemente una constante
entonces el límite de una constante es
exactamente la constante entonces esto
es fdc tenemos el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a c
fcc es igual a cero eso nos dice una
sola cosa si sumamos de ambos lados
fcc tendríamos del lado izquierdo límite
cuando x tiende a c df de x y como
sumamos fdc ya no lo tenemos del lado
izquierdo pero del lado derecho ahora
tenemos fdc de verdad 0 + fdc nos da fcc
entonces si nosotros recordamos la
definición de continuidad estamos
obteniendo esa propiedad verdad estamos
obteniendo justamente que la función es
continua
en el punto ce muy bien entonces a final
de cuentas que fue lo que hicimos
primero supusimos que f era derivable en
un punto de verdad y calculamos el
límite de fx - fcc cuando x tiende a c y
resulta va a ser cero verdad simplemente
de multiplicar y dividir por x menos c
ahora utilizando ese resultado vemos que
el límite de esta diferencia es la
diferencia de los límites y de ahí
concluimos que el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a c es fcc muy bien y con eso
estamos demostrando que es continua en
el punto c así que espero que te haya
gustado esta demostración